you ever think you
make vict I know this life for
me why would you bet on Goliath when we
got bet David value giv values
contagious this world are entrepreneurs
we G no value to haters how run homie
look what I become I'm the I'm the one
[Music]
okay so you know when when uh your name
is Tucker Carlson you go to Russia to
interview Putin which apparently it's
already done the interview's already
been done and and you get reaction from
media in the strangest way where a
Hillary Clinton had to be asked the
question and wait to see what she had to
say about it and and what she called
Tucker and what Korea she claims that
Tucker is going to have next morning Joe
responded to it everybody responded to
it and seems to be that a lot of these
people in media forget what they used to
once celebrate which Tom will show you
guys here in a minute but that's one of
the issues we definitely talk about it's
it's no longer speculation Tucker just
came out and said you know I am with uh
uh uh Putin I did do the interview or
I'm doing the interview and he gives his
reason and why and he has a message for
zalinski which is important for the
people that are zilinski folks to hear
what he has to say about that so we'll
we'll talk about that mayorcas border
we'll talk about that Joe Buck from the
NFL that he does I think he does Monday
Night Football with uh maybe he does
Sunday with Troy aan right the playoffs
for MLB yep Joe and Troy he said
something about Super Bowl that is very
weird why would a guy who does football
say that's Pro he says something big is
probably going to happen during the
Super Bowl right that's probably not a a
person would say that maybe it's an NBA
announcer maybe is a different sport an
maybe somebody who hates football would
say that but why would somebody in the
football space say something like that
we'll we'll play that clip for you and
we we'll talk about that On the Border
Side there's a few other things in
regards to record-breaking 57% of Voters
saying us Mexico border is in crisis
Christie big news for those of you guys
that are die had Chris Christie fans the
13 of you got that aren't listening to
this Chris Christie not ruling out
independent bit however there's a key
number folks you got to pay attention to
and some are saying he's already hit it
he said that he would need to see a path
to 270 some are saying he's already
across and Beyond the path of 340 but
that's a different kind of a path he's
on that maybe maybe we'll we'll address
here shortly yeah Democrats block
request to strip tech companies of legal
immunity related to child pornography
okay Democrats the hill covers that
South Carolina you guys ready for this
for for some people listening to this I
don't know if this attracts you to that
place or not but maybe it does can you
imagine if like 2.8 million people move
to South Carolina next month South
Carolina wants to start restart not
start meaning they used to do it wants
to restart executions using firing
squads yes and electric chair true story
we'll cover that New York uh uh NYPD I
think four months ago Eric Adams
introduced those rooc caps did you guys
see those rooc cops in New York they
introduced to yeah four months later
they're not working
$12,500 they're getting rid of it
there's Sports about guys stories about
guys uh pushing these cops over and they
don't retaliate can you imagine how
funny that ising New York bro all right
we'll talk Vegas to see who you got wait
to see who gets paid more money than
Brock pie uh uh it'll definitely
surprise you in 302 commercials for
Super Bowl ready $7 million highest ever
7 million bucks for 302
commercial Super Bowl bets could hit a
record-breaking
23.1 billion doll this year and I think
there's going to be a small little B
here being made as well shortly Disney
ready for this who wins the battle over
billionaires on Disney's board it's
actually very interesting story Tom I
actually want to get your take on this
and did you guys hear about Disney
announcing who may replace Johnny Depp
in Pirates of the Caribbean have you
seen this rap no have you seen who this
is Leta I just want to get your reaction
when I when you see it and it's not who
you think it is but obviously you don't
you you're not going to know who it is
but we'll cover that shortly more
Americans are getting a second job to
offset sting of inflation business
bankruptcy surch to 58% Chase will open
500 new branches over the next three
years wonder why guns abortion and lgbtq
laws are affecting where home buyers are
moving to redin says I've never thought
redin would have said gun abortion and
lgbtq laws but that's exactly what's
going on outrage as five trans students
dominate women
volleyball you
know let's go guys let's get boys beat
the girls good job feminist New York
Community Bank Corp stock uh Falls
nearly 25% credit card delinquency loans
are at the highest they've been in a
decade retail or sound alarm over
shipping delays price uh uh spikes and
then Super Bowl Usher won't be getting
paid for it Zoom cuts the think about it
zum was like the main name during Co
they've cut the de Focus team as
Corporate America Retreats on diversity
initiatives except for one person who's
a devout de guy very famous guy Mark
Cuban legendary big support those you
guys that love the Mark Cuban's your guy
before we get into it so last time on
Tuesday we announced anybody that buys
uh uh the future looks bright hats in
the gear and we said we want a million
people wear in this gear during these
strange times we want people walking
around saying hey I believe future looks
bright and getting the reaction from
other people when you wear that shirt at
the end of today's podcast we'll be
taking a raffle we have everyone's
orders we'll take a raffle two people W
will win a ticket $750 to come to the
Vault conference we'll be announcing
that at the end of the podcast on top of
that today we have some stuff that we
haven't given away we're continuing this
we sold out of a couple of our hats by
the way on Tuesday instantly Three Hats
sold out but anybody that buys any of
these gears Rob can we show this on the
camera so people can see it pick any one
of these hats and one of the future
looks bright shirts okay go a little
lower you got the purple one you got the
white one pick any of these trucker hats
for some of you guys that want the vment
logo with US flag next to it we also got
the pbd podcast hat there as well you
pick the black or white future looks
bright hat choose any of these
combination hat and a shirt you do next
week what we're doing is we'll be giving
away uh one of the Ryan Garcia signed
gloves a Trevor Bower signed ball and
and five signed choose your enemies
wisely live next Thursday next Tuesday
at the end of the podcast for home team
having said that let's get right into it
Tucker Carlson okay goes to Russia to
sit down with Vladimir Putin Rob did you
find a shorter version of the clip of
what Tucker says if you can find a
shorter version of it the world lost
their minds when this man announced that
he's going to Russia to sit down with
Tucker Carlson and to sit down with
Vladimir Putin the the amount of
reaction that people gave is absolutely
wild let me read the Newsweek story and
some people don't even want him to come
back to America by the way here we go
taker Carlson could face sanctions
sanctions over Putin interview Newsweek
story European Union lawmakers such as
former Belgian prime minister guy vorad
are contemplating sanctions against Tua
Carlson following his revelation of an
upcoming interview with Russian Vladimir
Putin he characterized Carlson as a
mouthpiece for Putin and former
president Donald Trump advocating for
potential travel bans within EU
countries can you imagine this that he
cannot travel to EU countries the eu's
external Action Service
EAS would require concrete evidence to
present to the European Council for any
sanctions against Carlson a process that
could be prolonged due to the balance of
direct sanctioning Authority for
individual Parliament members critics
highlight concerns over Carlson's
sympathetic portrayal of Russian
policies and his platforming of Putin
accus of war crimes suggesting that such
actions could compromise journalistic
integrity and warrant sanctions now Rob
if we can play a part of the clip of
what taker is saying while he's in
Russia go and play this clip in and
we'll react to it and they do that
mostly by
Omission for example since the day the
war in Ukraine began American Media have
spoken to scores of people from Ukraine
and they've done scores of interviews
with Ukrainian President zinski we
ourselves have put in a request for an
interview with seleni and we hope he
accepts but the interviews he's already
done in the United States are not
traditional interviews they are fawning
pep sessions specifically designed to
amplify zelinsky's demand that the US
enter more deeply into a war in Eastern
Europe and pay for it that is not
journalism it is government propaganda
propaganda of the ugliest kind the kind
that kills people at the same time our
politicians and media Outlets have been
doing this promoting a foreign leader
like he's a new consumer brand not a
single Western journalist has bothered
interview the president of the other
country involved in this conflict
Vladimir Putin most Americans have no
idea why Putin invaded Ukraine or what
his goals are now they've never heard
his voice that's wrong Americans have a
right to know all they can about a war
they're implicated in and we have the
right to tell them about it because we
are Americans too freedom of speech is
our Birthright we were born with the
right to say what we believe that right
cannot be taken away no matter who is in
the White House how do you debate that
right but they're trying anyway okay you
can pause it right there you can pause
it right there by the way while you're
seeing this can you play the Hillary
Clinton one I just I just want to kind
of give the contrast of what the here's
Hillary Clinton on uh I believe it's
MSNBC or NBC whoever it is goad and play
this real quick go for it is in Moscow
right now interviewing Vladimir Putin
right the first American I'll say
journalist uh to interview Putin since
the war in Ukraine began what does that
tell you about Tucker Carlson and
right-wing media and also Vladimir Putin
well it shows me what I think we've all
know he's what's called a useful idiot I
mean if you actually read translations
of what's being said on Russian media
they make fun of him I mean he's like a
puppy dog you know he somehow has after
having been fired from so many outlets
in the United States he uh I would not
be surprised uh if he emerges with a
contract with a Russian Outlet because
he is a useful idiot he says things that
are not true he parrots Vladimir Putin's
uh pack of lies about Ukraine uh so I
don't see why Putin wouldn't give she
straight jacket Pat she has buckles on
her like what so so how do how do you
process this Tom where are you at with
this year well first of all remember the
first rule of liberal attack in the
medium accuse the other guy of what
you're already doing 100% she's quoting
useful idiots which was the people that
were in Hollywood and the news media
when communism was trying to infiltrate
in the 19 late 50s and 60s that's a
phrase KL marks would use a lot use f
idiots so isn't it interesting excuse me
let me back up back up Red Line back up
intriguing and ironic that Hillary
Clinton would use the term useful idot
number one and number two I Marvel at
the way the left you know um deres the
opportunity to hear another Viewpoint
even if you think that other Viewpoint
is full of crap and by the way we used
to call that a presidential debate where
your guy would be on stage you thought
the other guy was full of crap right but
we wanted to hear it just the same
didn't We As Americans we wanted to hear
both sides wanted to see what they have
to say and going back 1977 they had a
hero in media her name was Barbara
Walter
let's take a look at this Rob look at
what glamour says when Barbara Walters
passed away in 1977 Barbara Walters
boldly went to Cuba to interview Fidel
Castro who was this dangerous communist
dictator that we were all upset about
and this is Barbara walters's interview
Clips are going viral in honor of the
broadcast icon these were clips of her
interviewing Castro what is the
difference between Barbara Walters going
to interview Castro during the Carter
Administration on the eve of Jimmy
Carter getting fired and replaced by
Ronald Reagan and Tucker Carlson go oh
wait on the eve of her retirement
Barbara Walters recalls a history making
interview with the Cuban president these
are this is Harper's bizar these were
quality Publications going out and just
absolutely lauding Barbara Walters who
was an icon of the one-on-one interview
before Larry King she was the go of a
one-on-one interview and there's a lot
of interviews she did that were really
good she Dove down and asked the
question she's a hero for against US
Government wishes sneaking into Cuba and
interviewing Castro and now here we are
these years later how quickly we forget
and suddenly Tucker Carlson is the
useful idiot interviewing Putin well
first and foremost like why why won't
she just go away I don't know about
everybody else out there I am sick and
what is her point of like who wants to
hear what Hillary Clinton has to say
about anything nobody cares about you
anything that wants if we want to talk
about Russia and puin how about you
being the problem because people are
still talking about it today seven years
later Russian collusion Trump wasn't
right you ruined single-handedly ruined
friendships families fighting Pol
everything was Russia Russia Russia
Russia Russia for the entire presidency
so I can care less what she's saying let
alone what she's wearing with her
freaking straight jacket but think about
this Pat 60 Minutes interviewed puin it
was journalism Megan Kelly it was
journalism uh Bloomberg interviewed
Vladimir Putin journalism Oliver Stone
interviewed Putin journalism Tucker
callling go it's treason and you know
why because during all those times we
weren in at war with Putin right now
they are begging to fight with this guy
and if we have somebody like Tucker
that's going to actually talk to him and
find out reason and stuff like that they
can't have that happen and and again and
I always say this thank God for Elon
Musk Patrick cuz if it wasn't for Elon
cuz this is Tucker on X you would never
ever see this or hear this and they are
going crazy and I absolutely love it
that this guy spent billions for us to
be able to hear this guy so other so
people can make up their minds either
way I think it's a great thing great
Point Adam thanks brother yeah I mean at
the end of the day uh people have to do
their job financial advisors they manage
money CPA they handle your taxes whether
you're an editor you edit whether you're
a coder you code if you're a basketball
player you shoot the ball if you're a
journalist you interview people yep
that's just what your job is he said
specifically I watched that whole
five-minute clip it's our job as
journalists Megan Kelly weighed in she
said it is our duty as journalists to
inform people so this is doing your job
second thing uh the truth people want to
know the truth he talks about this in
his F minute clip a ton they want to
know the truth that they're paying for
this the American people are paying for
this two years later most Americans are
not informed of what's actually going on
in Ukraine and Russia not that I'm
rooting for Russia we want to know the
truth number two they want to know the
truth about the human disaster the
long-term effects of this the the
post-ww World War II uh economic order
what's going on with that what's going
on with NATO are they're paying their 2%
everything goes on with that um he goes
on to speak more about the truth the
mainstream media they're corrupt they're
omitting everything they may not lie but
they'll omit so plenty of journalists
have interviewed zalinski we've seen
zalinsky how many times do an interview
dozens all the time he won't shut up so
magazine there there you go man of the
year in
2022 um and by the way speaking of Man
of the Year you don't have to agree or
they don't have to be a good guy or bad
guy I think Hitler was Man Of The Year
of Time Magazine uh in the 40s so I'm
not saying that Putin is Hitler but um
the last thing that that um Tucker
talked about was love love um he says um
I'm not here because I love Putin I'm
actually here because I love the United
States and I'm not encouraging you to
agree with Putin I'm encouraging you to
watch this yeah listen so I it's
important then last but not least he
gave a shout out to Elon Musk for not
suppressing or blocking the interview
and he promised to put it up but he said
Western governments will do their best
to censor the video uh and then he ended
it with don't be a slave watch the video
think for yourself what do you think so
couple things you know you you make very
good points uh Tom when you're talking
about Barbara Walters Mike Wallace I
don't know if you've seen the
documentary about Mike Wallace
phenomenal documentary on on what he did
his life the people he
interviewed and then you know he
interviewed Ki you ever seen can you
pull up Mike Wallace interviews Ki just
type in it's a very easy name to spell
just Mike Wallace
interviews k h o k h o m e i n I come on
Rob that's easy Rob what's wrong go to
images yeah right there just uh uh go to
images okay he's sitting right there
interviewing wow you know how many
people that man killed yeah do you know
how many people he killed and by the way
Mike Wallace was worried for his life
till last minute I'm sure and some of
the questions that they're asking
they're like I'm not going to ask the
question I'm not going to ask him that
question I need you to ask I'm not going
to ask him that question and he was
celebrated Mike Wallace also
interviewed I believe Mike Wallace go go
type in Mike Wallace interviewed uh uh
KKK uh what was the guy's name that he
interviewed some uh um he was a uh elen
Wallace or something right there look at
this Mike Wallace is sitting there
interviewing the main wizard you know or
imperial wizard of KKK and you're
learning about this person you you you
want to learn about the enemy now having
said
that the the one thing Hillary Clinton
said where she's wrong because she's
just a lot of lip service when when
you're when you're when you've had a
career career where the catalog is that
big and he can draw lines that you just
give lip service to sometimes senior
pastors do that they no longer prepare
for their speech they're no longer
prepared to preach because they've given
3,000 messages right so what do you do
you just give the same story of the same
this and the same that and then a new
32-year-old comes in fires up the crowd
as a new your church goes fired up
because you just kind of saying the same
thing she doesn't know how the Russian
people are reacting to it let me tell
you a guy who cannot stand Putin a
Russian man who can't stand Putin cannot
stand the fact that what he did to uh
zani what was his name what is the guy
that that was running against him uh
Alexi Nani n naali n like they wanted
him to win a guy that's Pro naali guy a
reporter
says yeah you know he's probably going
out there to do the interview with Putin
because Putin you know you know Tucker
is for Trump and Tucker is for this and
he's GNA and then the guy says the
interviewer asks him so how is the
Russian media treating Tucker being
there he says I don't know why but
they're celebrating they're loving
Tucker they're treating them so well
they're treating them royally they're
they're commenting on every single move
he makes he just bought this he just
went here he just ate here and they're
celebrating the fact that a person from
us is coming to interview him because
one thing about many of the Russian
people they actually admire the American
way because of capitalism and all this
stuff this is a guy that cannot stand
Tucker and this is a guy that cannot
stand Putin and then he says the
following to hold Tucker accountable he
says here's the thing we're going to see
if this is going to be a real interview
or not we're going to see if Tucker's
going to ask about the journalist that U
that uh Putin killed we're going to see
if he's going to ask about eliminating
his opponents we're going to see if
Tucker asked a tough question I think
Megan Kelly also said this when she was
commenting so so listen is a concern by
the way guys here's here's how the
market works the market Works in a a
following way the other day we uploaded
a video on on uh vment comedy right and
oh my god do we take it down look at the
comments all this I said no no no I
wanted to leave it I said leave all the
videos why because we are Talent we need
to see that the audience hates it say it
and then we sit and we feel like
and we improve right that's called
capitalism sometimes you got to lose
publicly and have that humiliating loss
that destroys your ego and you go home
and you either become a little female
dog you know there's a word for it I
don't know what the word is but you know
or you come out and you do something
about it right you you either become
this what so for Tucker Tucker said
something very interesting right there
he held himself accountable you know
what Tucker said Tucker said something
very powerful and when you say something
like that that is revealing that you're
going to do a tough interview what did
he say about zalinski what did he say
about all the media Outlets that
interview zalinski what was the word to
use propaganda he says all they're doing
is just doing basic easy interviews and
propaganda right so guess what Tucker if
you say something like that you better
do a tough interview Putin because you
can't say that and then not do that so
if he says that that tells you he's
asking the tough questions now Putin's a
what Putin's a at this phase when you
get to that point you're a professional
Communicator of course you've sat down
with Killers you've sat down with people
that want to take you out KGB you've sat
down with bosses you don't think that
guy has done some heavyweight sit Downs
where he knows the guy understands
Optics the guy understands eyeballs the
guy understands his own opponents
internally the people that hate him in
Russia the people that hate him in
America the guy understands election
year 2024 the guy understands how much
Biden's going to the guy understands all
of that because Putin is a
gangster gangsters understand this stuff
his life has been on the line for many
many years people internally wanted to
kill this guy morning Joe can you play
this clip on what morning Joe's reaction
has been to this by the way because
again Karine Jean was even asked about
it watch this one here go for it Rob a
Republican party that is now doing
Vladimir Putin's B Donald Trump always
did yeah uh but but but the Republican
party now in the house is doing Vladimir
Putin's bidding and somebody that we
know uh that we used to know uh going
over doing Vladimir Putin's bidding uh
attacking Western journalists saying if
only Western journalists would have come
over here and rep tried to even report
fairly on the war
well there have been Western journalists
that have gone over and tried to report
fairly on the war and they're in jail
they're in Googs right
now uh with the
person because Vladimir Putin doesn't
want willly Western journalists um going
over and asking honest questions fair
questions he'll he'll let puppets talk
to him but nobody else okay by the way
good point it's a good point that you
know going out there asking questions
but now here he has to ask about this
guy Evan gersic let me ask you a
question yeah would you consider Morning
Joe a
journalist at this point he's more of a
pundit than a journalist I think was he
at one point a journalist no he was a
congressman I think he's a former
Congressman Republican came in with the
Tea Party back in the day and now he's a
political talking head on MSNBC so he's
somebody just comments on it he's not a
journalist he's not repor let's go to go
put type in Morning Joe and see how
Wikipedia defines who this Joe guy is
let's go to Joe Scaro who I by the way I
think he's I actually like some of the
stuff he says so if you can go to Joe
scarbo and read his Wikipedia is he
categorized as a journalist or a pundit
he's a American tele ision host and
political attorney commentator and
former Congressman he's a host he's a
host so he's a commentator yeah okay can
you go to Tucker for a second and type
in Tucker Carlson and see what it says
about Tucker Carlson yeah go to Tucker
Carlson how does it Define who Tucker is
just go to his Wikipedia there you go
how does it Define Tucker Carlson
conservative political commentator again
commentator so neither one of them are
so they're the they they see the same
thing okay here's the difference Morning
Joe got a question for you brother
you're a good-looking guy you're well
spoken you were a conservative who went
to a liberal school and you were
destroyed the entire time and you kept
debating and fighting and getting better
at it until all of a sudden you just
became a mouthpiece yourself hey have
you at all uh uh decided to travel out
of that behind your desk and go sit down
with some other people in other
countries and maybe kind of give your
angle the story have you done that or is
it just comfortable going to the same
restaurants the same clubs the same
places are you willing to get on a plane
and go interview some of these people I
don't know did Joe go to the Border has
Joe gone to Maduro has Joe gone to
zalinski has Joe gone to Russia has Joe
gone to different places so maybe you're
a glorified podcaster is what you are
cool on mainstream media and that's what
you're doing meaning you're just kind of
giving your opinions and thoughts why
don't you do something about it if you
think the Western journalist isn't doing
it why don't you go approach these guys
and by the way maybe he has can you type
in uh uh people Joe Scarboro has
interviewed people Joe Scarboro has
interviewed intered Scaro has
interviewed I'm curious maybe I'm wrong
and he's interviewed some interesting
people Adam would you know who he's
interviewed I haven't watching in a
little while but he used to have a whole
host of um experts on the show
historians Admirals generals uh politic
chief of staffs he's had everyone um but
I it's not a lot of international
coverage from what I recall does does
does Tucker have how many kids does
Tucker have is it three kids three or
four Rob how many kids does Tucker have
you know how uh uh how many kids does he
have zoom in is it four Buckley Hy
Dorothy Lily okay Tucker's such a type
of guy that has a kid named Buckley so
well William Buckley maybe that's why I
don't know why it's Buckley but but
think about it from this standpoint okay
when you got a wife and kids and you
make your Millions you know what most
don't do they don't want to leave
anything within a 50 m radius and they
don't want to go on the road this guy's
going on the road okay this guy's going
but like we were the first on to sit
down with uh what do you call it uh uh
uh uh uh Tate after you know the he was
canel can all this stuff yeah went to
Romania you think it's okay okay boom
and what was it like you know what was
it like it was like you ready boom let's
go everybody was waiting to let's go
family all this stuff I respect a guy
like Tucker who's got a wife and four
kids that's willing to pause everything
and go to Russia you don't know how safe
you are at all and by the way he's doing
it while the administration doesn't like
him like it's safe if you go go talk to
Putin if Trump's president do you know
how risky it is to go while Biden's
president because watch this let's just
say let's just say let's let's play you
know a devil's advocate let's say he
asks a question that pisses Putin off he
staying there he's staying in Russia
okay and let's just say Putin says you
know what F you grab I told you don't
ask those three questions you ask those
three question arrest his 100% could do
it let's just say the chance of that
happening is 1% okay let's say it's 5%
whatever the number is he arrests him
okay Putin can say screw you guys watch
what you're doing with NATO you never
kept your War America let's say he does
that do you think Russia's going to
release Tucker in 2024 you think Biden's
going to go out there and do his best to
release Tucker hell no hell the no so
the fact that he did this good for him
now let's see how tough of an interview
it's going to be so what's going to come
down to it's tonight it's tonight at 6
right is that what I don't know when it
is pry sure i' love to know what
security concerns were implemented here
well that's a good Adam that's a great
point you make up as of right now though
think about this Tucker's wife those
four kids the house everything Tucker's
communication is all under surveillance
you know everybody out there should know
that and it's going to be for a while
they're going to be watching his ass and
he's tapped because they already tapped
them twice they were monitoring him so
God bless him well and by the way note
to Joe Scarboro you know congratulations
in the ratings through December 30th
2023 you are holding on to 24th Place in
the total ratings are youing shows on
American television and you are only the
number ninth most popular Show on MSNBC
I am not where's that data I just went
to it I went to deadline which is a
source of ratings and the United States
television database that says Morning
Joe barely Garners 967 967 th000 viewers
on an average day 1,67 average on
Fridays is the ninth most popular show
on NBC currently trailing in fifth place
and can you send that to rap and
number24 overall on TV Tom Joe maybe go
out someplace and get something that
people want to watch and it would
actually help your ratings Tom can you
send that to Rob Garo go ahead and you
know what's crazy though because and you
know why right because Trump when when
Trump was in that's all they did all
these people only existed because of
Donald Trump it was just Trump and
Russia and spy and the phone call and
zalinski and all that crap pad they're
dying cuz they have nothing to talk
about nobody wants to listen to Jo by
the way so check this out this thing is
going to get more views on one podcast
than Morning Joe will get in year and
nine months I agree let me say that one
more time cuz if he averages
900,000 five Fray 4 and2 yeah 4 and 1/2
time 52 weeks weeks is what roughly 220
million 220 million time 1 and A5 is
around 330 million the interview on
Twitter is going to get probably 400
million views bananas so he's going to
get more views on one podcast talk to
Carlson Mr Joe yep then Joe's going to
get in 1920 months wow yeah that's what
it is so good for you you're right the
market is going to decide really uh if
Tucker can he's fighting to maintain
that pth look at that those flat ratings
Morning Joe fighting to maintain
his place well the market is going to
decide whether Tucker is really who he
is or if he just talks about it because
with all with the backdrop of what's
going on with journalists this guy Evan
gerscovich if you ever look at the Wall
Street Journal there's not a day that
goes by that they're not talking about
this journalist or giving a tribute to
Evan gerscovich because he's been locked
up in Russia we saw what happened with
Jamal gasogi with NBS in Saudi Arabia
journalist hacked to death we've and
Tucker's last interview with Donald
Trump it was labeled a softball
interview that was interviewed during
the debates so Tucker has a chance to
show that I am the biggest baddest most
credible journalist on the planet and
I'm going to sit face to face with
Vladimir Putin and the market will
decide and you whether he is or not the
one thing I hate P I don't want to stand
this I know you want to move on the one
thing that I hate that everybody that's
on the left always say puin this
murderer and he kills and hold on a
second guess what we killed too I don't
know if you guys remember that guy
George Bush uh Jr killed over with that
war a million Iraqis every all everybody
all together for no war there was no war
he does Putin have that many bodies
under his belt I don't think I I know
he's a bir he kills people but we're bad
too embrace your inner Donald Trump
Vinnie what I don that he's a republican
what George Bush Jor the the famous uh
you think we're so innocent too oh I I I
honestly don't even remember that but
guess what remember that one no I don't
I'm being genuine no but but I love the
he's a killer yeah so are we we're
really good Killers literally what Trump
said guess I'm trying why don't we
transition into something more subtle
South Carolina wants to restart
executions using fire squads firing
squads and electric chairs okay so
they're tapping into their inner uh uh
Russia some of the names you're talking
about here so South Carolina wants to
restart executions using firing squads
and electric chairs this is a Daily Mail
story uh uh South Carolina's pushing to
reintroduce firing squads prompting
prompting legal challenges from death
row inmates Grayson Lambert representing
Governor Henry MC mcmaster's office
argues that courts have never mandated
executions to be instantaneous or
painless despite 33 inmates awaiting
execution in South Carolina and no exec
executions conducted since 2011 due to
drug supply issues the debate over
capital punishment intensifies
alternative methods like nitrogen gas
employed in Alabama face criticism for
potential cruelty with experts
cautioning against its use Alabama
attorney general Steve Marshall defends
the use of nitrogen gas and executions
labeling it a proven method Marshall's
remarks Comm amidst controversy over its
efficacy and ethics highlighting ongoing
debat surrounding the implementation of
capital punishment methods Tom oh my
thoughts on this
well first of all apparently South
Carolina is is concerned that Nikki
Haley's coming back
so the um so interesting announcement
comes out at that time the um so there's
a couple things going on here I I think
you've got overcrowded prisons and
you've got career Killers remember these
are not necessarily single single
incident Killers these are career
murderers multiple murders multiples or
have been reiv rate and then committed
another murder these are people on death
row that are basically you know serving
double life terms and people like South
Carolina are saying hey you know what
maybe it's time to start the executions
again will this be a deterrent and it
makes a headline where he says hey
nobody said you want to talk about the
you want to talk about painless let's
talk about the victims let's get the
coroners in here and the medical
examiners and say how did the victims
die was that painless and so maybe it's
time and then they talk about cruel and
unusual punishment but let's face it
you're going to be killed it's not
necessarily Pleasant and I'm I finally
you know resolved in my mind that I
think too much time is spent trying to
you know pacify a bunch of people you're
you're implementing an execution Rob can
you look up what states do uh electric
chair or executions you know stuff like
that we'll pull that out while I'm going
to Vinnie go for it I mean well excuse
me Tom great point at the fact that you
said uh Nikki Haley's from South
Carolina there must be something in the
water there like people are just angry
bitter war hawk attitude but I don't
know if you guys if you guys uh mold
over this but look the governor uh Henry
mccaster Grayson lamber who's
representing the governor basically the
governor is arguing hey they never said
these these deaths had to be uh
instantaneous or painless they want them
to suffer which is which is kind of
crazy but guys and this is one more
thing that jumped out at me Pat there
there's no executions conducted since
2011 you know why drug supply issues
they can't get the drugs to kill these
wait a minute let's just go down to
Eagle Pass and get fentel we have more
than enough fentel coming from China
Eagle Pass say I know a guy that can get
you guys just fentanyl just hit g i I
need 8 O of fentanyl by Monday no
problem he G but I I I do the the one uh
positive thing I do see about this is if
you're in South Carolina and you're
thinking about doing some crazy and
killing and murdering people just know
like these guys are trying to kill you
but not in a humane way they want to
shoot your ass or they want to
electrocute your ass and I don't know if
you guys have ever seen cuz I have and I
I'll I hate it to this day have you ever
seen somebody in electric chair like one
of these videos that it's not good you
ever SE the ones when they don't work
and he's like yeah it was in the green m
i saw it's not good but maybe that could
Stoke a little bit of fear in these
people before they go murder a Florida's
electric chair was known for malfunction
and and a governor of Florida you can
look this up nicknamed the electric
chair old Sparky oh yeah says we'll just
get him a seat in Old Sparky and the
hood apparently and I don't know if this
is yep yeah old
Sparky and Florida apparently Florida
was the one that introduced the hood
because you know they have the eyes and
stuff pop out yeah there's there's bad
things that happen with your head when
you put a lot of heat and volts into it
by way do you cover him with a head with
a hood do you know how many states allow
firing squads Rob Google this please
very weird legal executions firing squad
Google that oh there you go look at this
as of 2023 Mississippi Oklahoma South
Carolina Utah used the firing squad for
the death penalty in 2023 Idaho and
Tennessee were debating about using the
firing squad that that is that's like
they hang on hang on let me see if I can
I'm wondering if this is going to come
out of the bisoc hard drive here um I've
not been looking anything here but I
think the last firing squad execution in
United States was Gary Gilmore in Utah
Rob can you look that up and and while
while he's looking that up why do you
know that Tom cuz Tom's the bisdak but
you know oh Utah but it was Utah give
Utah Credit a different guy and there's
actually I know I I don't know if I
don't know if the United States does
this but I think for some of these fire
squads uh guys so they don't like have
to have PTSD or the self like be
conscious some of the like say there's
five Shooters three of them have blanks
and only two guys have actual bullets so
nobody at the end of the day can say for
a fact that I'm the one that killed this
person so it actually helps the shooting
officer so they don't have to you know
there's always that question of did I do
it or did Johnny do well the previous
conversation we had you know the
difference between you know American
values or Western values or what Putin
or something would do you know at least
we're having this conversation in
America of what is appropriate uh cruel
and unusual punishment what is
considered the right way to implement
the death penalty what is the right
conversation to have around capital
punishment where in Russia you'll just
end up throwing out of
window you just end up being poison
drink you end up uh bullet back of
head more creative they sprayed polonium
Vapor on the back of a uh dissident do
you look this up Rob they sprayed
radioactive vapor in a bar on the back
of the guy's head and on his neck and he
died in a hospital it took it took weeks
for the guy to die and there's no
there's no uh investigation it just
happens you know what speaking of this
the biggest news in the world was uh 6
months ago or so when the the Wagner
group guy basically had to try to do a
revolt against Russia what happened what
was his name again anyone I don't forget
we remember his name at this point
radioactive Rob okay this guy yep there
he is yeah this Liv men no this is a
different guy this was a dissident from
mercury poison yes this guy just ends up
dead uh his plane is shot down the
Wagner group guy so pran pran exactly so
the difference between America and
Russia at least we can have this
conversation what's cruel what's not
cruel each State can decide for
themselves that's the beauty of
America's well you know look you know
South Carolina might be a firing squad
here but in Russia you might just be
poisoned to death with zero
accountability so at least in America we
still have this conversation of what is
cruel and what is unusual and what is
the appropriate amount of punishment
it's crazy that you're saying that cuz
you know that because Mississippi
stopped doing uh one of these methods
that was way too cruel and unusual they
would tie up the person that was on
death row and just to torture them and
ruin them and they some of them winded
up kill themselves they would put on the
show The View and they would watch it
and they would want to kill themselves
torture is this a true story I think I
heard something like that where they
were just like I'd rather they just to
way to go though that's tough could you
imagine being tied up and your eyes
stuck open and you have to watch Whoopi
andjoy that's that is cool and you're
totally disgusting you're totally
channeling uh Stanley Kubrick's the
Clockwork orang that's ex it Tom like
that's of course I did and they held the
eyes open made them watch imagine that
don't kill this guy the wor torture what
do you think about by the way what do
you think about it what do you think
about firing squat death penal you know
death penalty executions what do you
think about that it's supposed to be a
deterrent B stock out what what do you
think about it I mean I actually believe
in the death penalty it's like if you
like the mass Shooters don't get me
started on these people these kids we're
going to get there at some point the the
the people that go in and and and murder
innocent people and mass Shooters School
shooters these people should be held
accountable to the highest level well
that's highest level that's a great
question cuz I want to ask you Tom and
you uh in the Bible I know people always
misinterpret the eye for an eye but if
this person is out there and they're
killing and they kill a family okay and
then we have them Tom are we supposed to
let them live out their life pay tax our
tax dollars to keep them alive till they
die peacefully or do you think we take
action and we actually end this person's
life uh eye for an eye you take them
outside you they they talk
about the trial they talk about judging
they talk about Witnesses they talk
about valuation then they talk about
take them outside the camp and stone
them oh so well because Adam because I'm
telling you a lot of people have all
these opinions until it happens to you
until your family gets killed and you
see this person in court you're like I
don't just have them killed once in a
blue moon you see the parent want to hug
the killer which is well you saw what
happened with Jennifer Crumbley you saw
that right are you following that story
I followed it so jury finds Jennifer
Crumbley the Michigan school shooter's
mother
guilty of manslaughter okay of
manslaughter uh this is the killing of
four students in 2021 making her the
first parent in the US to be held
responsible for a child carrying out a
mass shooting uh School attack Vinnie I
know you got into the responsib by the
way this is one of those stories P like
at the beginning where we're like f
finally cuz me and AD we talked about
this on many many podcasts before Adam
what do we do with people that are
shooter people said that I was crazy cuz
I said you should you should hold the
parents or the family accountable no
they got mad at me you account if
14-year-old kid breaks a window next
door you have to pay for it yeah so
prosecutors say that um excuse me
Jennifer Crumbley had a duty under state
law to prevent her son who was 15 at the
time mind you uh from harming others she
was accused of failing to secure a gun
and ammunition at the home and failing
are you ready for this this is I love
this guys to help to support Ethan
crumley's mental health meaning Adam the
signs were there the kid was crazy and
you let him go out there and kill
everybody so I think this is great news
cuz it'll give people in that state a
wakeup call look up at look after your
kids don't just give them an iPad and
just go in the other room pay attention
get involved and I mean Paramount first
and foremost lock up your gun if you
have a kid in the house and they take
that gun and they go shoot somebody you
belong in jail 100% and here's the thing
Adam the max maximum for a manslaughter
is 15 years so uh prosecutors have have
not said if they're going to ask for
consecutive sentences of all four
convictions which could mean uh 60 years
in jail for her this is again like we're
talking about like death penalty for
these killers how about parents you
better guess what if your kid's wearing
a trench coat and writing manifestos and
going one day people are going to find
out you better check his ass cuz proba
we need gun control in the country we
don't need this it's all that but wait a
minute what was she failing to control
with her child hold on one second
support his uh his mental health oh it
is a mental health issue yeah Oh I
thought it was the gun climbed out of
the drawer and that's why we need gun
control and we need all kinds of things
like this so now it is mental health we
do need to look at America's youth we do
need to support them identify what's
going on and find ways to help moderate
their condition and gosh I was so
confused all this time and I and great
you just made me think of that too that
same monitoring with the mental health
guess what same like monitor look at
them just with this whole with the whole
trans movement with all these young kids
is like hey talk to your kid let them
know that what they're going through
might be a phase they might grow out of
it you're confused talk to them because
and then you have like that father in
New York what he wrote he he wrote in a
journal I'm sorry finished no but you
know what I mean like like for instance
get involved with your kids I know that
father is trying to stick up and God
bless him for 5-year-old trans kid and
then this mother it's a different
situation but talk to your kids that's
why cuz they're disconnected they're on
Tik Tok and they're all these apps and
they're like gay oh you know trans trans
trans I could be a boy I could be a girl
that's you have to get involved because
things like Jennifer Crumbley tells the
juror that it was her husband's job to
keep track of the gun she also said she
had she saw no signs of mental distress
in her son we would talk we did a lot of
things together I trusted him and I felt
I had an open door he would come to me
about anything he's saying this in a
journal found by police Ethan Crumbley
wrote that his parents wouldn't listen
to his plea for help I have zero help
this is the kid saying I have zero help
for my mental problems and it's it's
causing me to shoot up the school oh he
wrote in his journal prosecutors
introduce evidence that even Ethan
Crumbley texted his mother in Springer
of 2021 about demons throwing bows and
other hallucinations but she told the
juror that it was just Ethan messing
around I have asked myself if I would
have done anything differently I
wouldn't have I wish he would have
killed us instead is what the mother
said this is but what a great find
though but like denial is a powerful
drug kid is saying demons I'm seeing
demons and I want to shoot up things
it's you have to get involved you can't
say oh we we thought he was joking are
you nobody kids around like what's that
saying if you see something say
something even if it's your kid you got
to you got to nip that in the butt get
him help and get him admitted if he has
to it's ridiculous just from a bigger
standpoint uh you know a lot of words
have been thrown around especially over
the last few years about the
weaponization of the justice department
and how corrupted it is
um we're lucky that we still live in
America and we still have the um the
Jewel of the world when it comes to uh
human rights and uh trial by jury and a
trial by your peers and uh the basically
everything that encompasses the sixth
amendment now you can you can criticize
it all you want but where else in the
world where you can basically actually
not be in other parts of the world
poisoned thrown off roofs we saw what
happened in Andrew taton Romania just
held without cause what's going on there
in Hamas land you can just be stoned or
thrown off a roof for allegedly cheating
on your wife or husband sorry on your
husband or your gay whatever it is at
least in America we have a justice
department that is the Jewel of the
world and you can criticize it all you
want but believe me if you if you're
accused of something and you're arrested
you'd much rather be in America than
anywhere else in the world dealing with
our jce 100% let forget that as messed
up as it gets with that behind and
everything I still would rather get so
so Tom are you also for the mother going
to jail for the amount of years that
she's going to for this I think under
appeal the number of years is going to
come down I think up to 60 years that
that's a headline and then you know good
behavior and stuff I mean but you're
good with this is the first time in US
history ever because because I I got to
tell you it it this this okay so
question what's scarier what's scarier
fire Squad execution or parents going to
jail for a stupid thing a crime like
this a crazy crime that Ethan committed
what's scarier what is going to scare
the world more okay popul more this or
firing squad this I think so as well
because listen I got parents are
accountable folks people don't know it
but wait till your kid you involved with
five other kids and went out and tagged
the house broke windows and everything
and he's 13 years old and then the
police say by the way you don't have to
worry about the police you have to worry
about the homeowners insurance and
something called subreg and subur means
we go after the guilty party your
insurance company let's say somebody
hits you in a parking lot you're walking
out from Target you see somebody bash
into your car and then your your
insurance company is going to take care
of your car but your insurance company
has got people that are going to move
heaven and elf hell to go after that
person that ran into your car it's
called subreg it also happens you you um
you go to the doctor and you you have an
injury they will call you and interview
you about where the injury occurred and
the insurance company will go after so
those insurance companies are going to
go after the kids that broke up a house
and things like this and then it's going
to go after the parents they're
responsible you have to pay for it and
so this is just logical end of that this
makes me this makes me think about like
if you if you're if you're Trojan
condoms as a company right this is is
this is this is this has got to increase
people buying condoms right number two
if you think about it this is also the
perfect example of the wrong people
having way too many kids and the right
people having way too few kids we're
having irresponsible people that should
not be parents who don't have the right
values to teach their kids having too
many kids and we're having people that
are responsible that can teach the right
values afraid of having kids that is a
big problem that we're facing today and
why is that because our incentive
program incentivizes to wrong people to
have way too many kids it's just our
incen and it goes all the way back to
back to LBJ I talked about this with
Pierce on his show yesterday Pierce
Morgan when he asked me about you know
kids parenting father you know all this
stuff
um to by the way to the wrong to the
wrong parents who have kids I know a lot
of people who have kids like this this
should scare the crap out of those
parents Rob this is in what state this
is Michigan michig she a is this going
to be this is a blue State L but Tom is
this something a law in one state
doesn't necessarily apply to another
state right that other state has to have
a first case for people to say you know
this is what happened similar to such
and such case right right but a district
attorney say in Indiana actually it
doesn't even have to be Indiana it can
be freaking Florida can did did the
State Attorney General can say can he
use that as what happened in Michigan
well they can't use it as a legal
precedent direct but they can use it and
say look folks they just did it in
Michigan we think it's a good precedent
and I'm going for it here and so the
State Attorney General you can do go
with the State Attorney General of
Florida in this case to answer your
question could say you know what I think
what happened in Michigan was good bring
me the first case in Florida I want
what's called a landmark case in Florida
bring it to me put it on my desk we're
going to charge them if that make if
they make that a nationwide thing Pat I
guarantee you the the mass shootings are
going to drop 100 that's you know you
say don't say say 100% 100% it would
drop because that means those the
parents of those kids now are going to
be like wait a minute he's wearing a
trench co wait what are you talking
about they're going to get involved so
then here's my other question gun
storage so here's my here's my other
question for you Tom so you know how in
New York when they came out with that
four-month window or whatever it was
that you can you know cobak and me too
and then Eric Adams got hit up and then
you know Jamie Fox got hit up and all
these guys and P didy got hit up like 28
times and all these guys are like going
back can people now use this to go back
to previous mass shootings to go get
their parents to go to jail wow good
question well New York has set a look
back president haven't they and so you
if we're going to allow look back
responsibility in New York in that case
then hell yes some Cas some Court May
test the look back provision remember
you can't be tried twice our
constitution guarantees that you can be
tried once and then if the statue of
limitations is moved and they decide to
go go back and try people um under a
look back provision look out I guarantee
you right now okay parents who have lost
a child to mass shooting just made a
phone call a minute after this was
finalized that she's going to jail they
all called each other there's a grp
WhatsApp group me going on with all
those surviving the the parents of who
lost child to a mass shooting they're
texting each other in a group of me
saying let's do a class action and let's
go put all of these guys behind in jail
because they're responsible for it how
many of those phone calls are being made
right now think about that great Point
Coline shooters for young men people are
about to get some very interesting
knocks hey you knew hey you knew you
didn't do anything about it this this
could set the precedent for a lot of we
do not be surprised if in the next 30 60
90 days throughout the rest of the year
more stories like this come out of
previous events that sick good yeah so
anyways interesting well we'll see what
happened here next story uh let's go
through to mayorcas okay so house votes
on mayorca impeachment as US Senate
border deal collapses Rob if you want to
put up the video I don't know if you
have it or not it's like 3 seconds not a
big deal it's like 15 seconds of him uh
losing uh uh what clip is this Rob the
one day you have with news nation that
was a different one let me grab it all
right let me just read the story here
and then whatever you find we we'll show
it to you I didn't ask you about that
prior so uh house votes on mayorcas
impeachment as Senate border deal
collapses this is a wsj story Wall
Street Journal house Republic narrowly
failed in their bid to impeach Homeland
Security secretary Alejandro mayorcas
with a vote of 214 to 216 against by two
highlighting the party struggle to
United contentious issues amid a SL slim
majority and fierce immigration policy
debate despite mayorcas being a primary
target of Republicans for the surge in
border crossings including record high
levels the impeachment effort faces
challenges with only four Republicans
joining Democrats in opposing it the
attempt underscore the intense politics
surrounding immigration and the
consequences of policy disagreement
within a party while mayorca defens his
record calling the impeachment effort
false and arguing that border
enforcement can be both tough inhumane
critics within the go GOP such as
representative Kim Buck highlighted that
behavior while deemed incompetent did
not meet the threshold for impeachment
under the Constitution Vinnie I well
first off the the four uh Republicans
that are just staying on the sideline
this is just more proof to everybody out
there that it's a uni party there's no
left there's no right this guy mayorcas
the bureaucrat or I'm sorry bureaucrat
uh has done the worst job of of securing
our most important thing which is our
border he is let in by by the end of
this Administration there's going to be
at least what 20 20 to 22 million is the
is the real number and guess what's
going to happen nothing to him zero
accountability you're see right now they
can't even and Peach him and he's going
to have Secret Service protection just
like the other guy Dr fouchi the other
rat for the rest of his life our tax
dollars are going to pay this guy to be
protected because the people know what
he's done and what he's doing and I I
cannot stand when he's been in front of
and you guys can all YouTube all the
Congressional hearings that he's sitting
there how's grilling him uh Gramma is
grilling him and he's just sitting there
with a smug face laughing at all of us
because he knows nothing will happen to
him cuz he's protected okay he did his
job say what you want he did his job he
did just like Biden's doing his job he
did his job and I think it's absolutely
ridiculous and I'm going to Once Tom
says his thing P I'm going to go into
another thing that mayorcas has been up
to this weekend uh the part of the quote
that I loved from um from rep Ken Buck
is his behavior while deemed incompetent
you know that means did not meet the
threshold for impeachment unbelievable
so it means you're he's hiding behind a
SPL litting of a hair is what he's doing
but he feel hey the guy's incompetent
and he's incompetent about what about
our border and he's Secretary of what oh
gosh you know Homeland Security so
Homeland Security Guys is incompetent
and you're splitting it well it didn't
meet the threshold for impeachment you
just said he was incompetent what the
hell a very good point that you're
making by the way before I come to you
record-breaking 57% of Voters say US
mexical border is in crisis okay as a
top priority and on top of that Alaska
National Guard planning deployment to US
border with Mexico the Alaskan Army
National Guard has been notified by
National Guard Bureau that it is
authorized to begin training in
preparation for possible mobilization to
support the federal Southwest border
mission in early fiscal 2025 Major
General torren saaks of Alaska National
Guard said the memorandum directs the
Alaska Army National Guard general
support Aviation Battalion to be
prepared to deploy two l U7 to Lakota
helicopters and 20 Guardsmen uh
consisting of air air crew M maintenance
Specialists and other Personnel to the
border so it's not it's not just
something right now that they're sitting
around saying well it's not really a big
deal Americans are not happy about it
57% Alaska National Guard being asked by
National Guard to go to it Adam your
thoughts on the story the whole thing
well we know that the uh situation in
the border is of freaking disaster our
immigration uh system is completely
broken this is nothing new uh but if we
learned anything from the Trump
Administration if we're talking about
this guy mayorcas and getting impeached
for how many times was Trump to try to
they tried to impeach him two three
times whatever it was we had to learn
something from that though guys uh what
did we learn we learned that um in order
to impede somebody you must um they must
be they they must fit uh the crime of
high crimes and misdemeanors that's what
it comes down to you've heard this a
million times High crimes and Mis
meaners High crimes and Mis meaners what
the hell does that mean so what they one
of the guys who actually uh one of the
House Republicans that actually voted
not to impeach mayorcas his name is Mike
Gallagher he's a republican out of
Wisconsin he actually wrote an editorial
in the Wall Street Journal as to why he
didn't want to impeach um mayorcas who's
nobody's saying that he's doing a great
job great he's not doing his job at all
Adam well it's period but you here's
where you're wrong go ahead because he
actually is doing his job um and this is
what it comes down to is that uh it's
not high crimes and misers because he's
actually enforcing the Biden policy so
here's where it gets into the Nuance of
why he did not impeach him because
you're like oh he sucks he sucks at his
job his job is to follow policy is to
follow the law at the end of the day the
law of the land is an open border policy
implemented by the the Biden
Administration so the the the biggest
person that we should be yelling at that
we should be you know shouting our fist
at in the air is not mayorcas he's
actually following the policy he could
quit Adam if he has a conscience and a
soul he should quit listen hold on a
second because he's been with Biden
since the beginning where he was sitting
in Congress and that's there's a there's
a famous speech where uh Biden's like
you know hey bring everybody in he goes
I want uh I want everybody to be of
Eastern Europe P stock and mayor is
sitting in there smiling with him but
just just another fun fact I want
everybody to know this you know the
Eagle Pass where those thousands and
thousands were coming every single day
and the government was suing you know
that Biden fist in there Biden was suing
them to take it down guess what since
the barb wire has been up it went from a
couple thousand guess how many has been
Crossing since then three think about
this everybody a little razor wire
stopped the entire migration people
illegal Crossing so you know instead of
that $118 billion that they want to send
to Ukraine and all this time out
spend a couple hundred million put razor
wire everywhere the hell with the wall
put Razer wire on top of razor wire on
top of razor wire it's working look at
this Eagle Pass border crossing dumped
to thousands per day to three guess what
I don't you don't need to be a freaking
rocket scientist but to know the
government is suing Texas because it
works so myor is as much out of my get
what you're saying though guess what if
you have a conscience if you have a soul
guess what I'm stepping down I can't do
the dirty work for you guys anymore no
matter how much of a bureaucrat no
matter how loyal he is to the party get
the hell out of here dude I'm with you
100% what what's happening at the border
is a freaking disaster uh I'm just
giving you the the rationale from the
Republican Congress person why he did
not vote to impeach him basically said
he they used a term that I've never
heard before we called maladministration
basically bad policy mhm so can you
impeach somebody from Bad policy
essentially no you can call them an
idiot you can call him a you could
basically say you're a bad person but
you're actually followed the law which
is ridiculous and redundant at this
point but you're right now shout out to
Governor Abbott because basically he has
nationalized what's happening in Texas
now the people in New York you see Eric
Adams comparing himself to Jesus at this
point you see what's going on there he's
shipping them off to Chicago Sanctuary
cities this is the number one issue in
America right now it's no longer
inflation and the only problem is it's
not going to be solved why cuz Donald
Trump doesn't want them to solve it
right now cuz this is a campaign issue
this is the biggest campaign issue for
him this is going to what's going to
allow him to say I told you so I alone
can fix it what was his latest tweet
that he talked about this he said if you
want a really secure border your your
only hope is to vote for Trump in 2024
they don't want this fixed Trump wants
to run on this issue it needs to be
fixed but his political talking point
and it'll be the number one talking
point in the election in he's 100% right
go go go to Twitter rap go go to Twitter
I fully agree with what he's saying here
uh so me yeah of course zoom in so zoom
in go to the bottom one right there
click on that one right there the that
tweet so I tweeted this yesterday
Republicans got piss saying why are you
giving a strategy I'm like this is
exactly so watch this why call it a
border bill when 20 out of 118 is going
to the southern border meanwhile over
50% it's going to Ukraine 60 bilon just
call it the Ukraine bill by the way tip
to Democrats this where I want to go to
who really want to be Trump in 2024
watch this a six seven step program
actually use 100% of it towards
protecting the bill it'll shock the
Republicans number two suspend all
Asylum and immigrants come to America
for the rest of 2024 number three build
even a bigger ball with the 118 billion
to make it nearly impossible to cross
number four double down on Border Patrol
and actually arrest those who disrespect
America number five send military
personnel to the border for the rest of
the year number six send your most
influential Democrats to the border and
document it invite every single media
Outlet to recorded all Obama's Clinton's
Pelosi just Nancy keep PA at home Nome
Camala AOC even Biden's and last but not
least Haley yes Haley she's a Democrat
invite celebrities as well to the show
to show how much you care I have three
other items I'm not going to cover those
three if you do that you'll actually
show the people you're putting America
First instead of Ukraine the question is
will you do it that's strategy chance if
they do this MH the campaign for Trump
Chang es immediately but the chance of
them doing this is slim to none slim
you're giving them the recipe but
they're not
cooking no way they're going to do by
the way let me let me show you a couple
other things on what's going on with
Oakland V did you see the video that
came out about Apple Store it just was
released a couple hours have you seen
that it's crazy okay so check this out
let's go through California and let's go
through Nome what a phenomenal job he's
doing for the State of California and
before I get into telling you what's
going on with California this is just
another day in Oakland this is yesterday
go and play this rap Oakland California
the mall they're not doing nothing and
by the way in front of everybody boom oh
he's by himself this dude ain't even
wearing a mask and no one is doing
nothing by the way that's already I
think 14 16 18
19 look at that 19 that's 23 oh right
there's $35,000 right there $40,000 Oak
in the house this guy efficient watch
with the other doing nothing she's just
making a phone call hey babe he bab
where do you want to eat lunch yeah boom
I'm
out and there's a cop outside there's a
cop car out there
oh what the hell nothing dude gets in
his car guy even recording it
docum watch this watch this's going to
get caught Nome sending 120 California
Highway Patrol officers to Oakland to
crack down on alarming crime surge okay
alarming crime surge like I wonder why
maybe because it's okay to do so in many
parts of California it's called bad
policies have
consequences so so uh uh uh California
governor Nome response decisively to the
surgeon crime Oakland by deploying 120
Highway Patrol officers and what's
happening in this beautiful City and
surrounding areas alarming and
unacceptable right this deployment
signifies a Monumental increase in state
law enforcement presence constituting a
100% surge in Personnel aiming to
address the significant rise in violent
crime robbery vehicle theft rates
observed in 2023 with increases of 21%
38% and 45% in robbery vehicle theft
rates uh uh respectively significantly
surpassing other Urban centers in
California by the way on top of that
Oakland local saddened disappointed
after Kaiser warned staffers to stay
inside at lunch over crime
worries okay I'm not going to read all
of these for you I'm just going to give
you the headlines okay I mean California
is shocked by electric bill rate hikes
like you're getting punished California
many California residents such as
90-year-old Dorothy LVL and Rebecca gyos
Express shock over soaring utility bills
with level describing it as almost like
you're getting punished and gyo stating
she was blown away by her
$162 increase increase Pacific Gas and
Electric Company implemented a 35
monthly $35 monthly increase for
customers approved by the California
Public Utilities Commission tolling to
over $400 annually aimed at wildfires
according to pg& spokesman
Lindsay Paulo PJ offers assistant
programs relief assistant etc etc so
California a mess Oakland a mess prices
a mess gas prices a mess electric prices
a mess safe
a mess
yet Bill Mah loves winner his hair is
good loves his hair is good and you
forgot the crap in the streets which is
another so but by the way Tom you see
stuff like this we're all California
right you see the stuff at you know
Apple Store the guy steals $50,000 of
phones give or take I don't know what
they sell those phones so nowadays 2500
bucks $2,000 and no nobody's nothing you
know cops outside not arresting not
doing that's a cop right out out of
apple doing nothing what the hell is
going on with California Mr Thomas El
well I'll tell you what's going on first
of all it's election year and this is
not the first time that Nome is and by
the way did you see the word they got
dropped into the story there on behalf
of Gavin Nome acted
decisively to do this and so basically
he knows his policies have created
problems and now he's trying in an
election year to look decisive he also
about four 5 months ago we remember we
had the um uh the folks from England on
the show that were talking about
recovery from trans how he had come back
and one of the things he pointed out was
that Nome had recently passed a bill
that enhanced sanity and um with regard
to custody in the courts remember that
he came sweeping in and did that and he
came sweeping in and said driverless
trucks need to have a a co-driver for
safety on the roads this guy is creating
problems and then in an election year
Sweeping in to make the guy make himself
look like he's solving them that's
what's happened in California the thing
on the um electric bill tax how long the
state of California has been ined with
pg& and didn't have them upgrading all
that equipment with those long high
tension wires that go through the forest
that were arcing and creating the fires
that was aging equipment guess what now
everybody in California gets to pay for
it you know this is this is a failed
leader this guy is coming out here
feigning you know that that he's out
there trying to help and be your hero
he's not he's created the problems he's
perpetuated the problems and now oh it's
election year I'm sending 120 Highway
Patrol guys to come Happ you wait a
minute wait a minute this is not Somalia
Oakland has a police force Greenlight
them to do their job rather than
handcuffing them and not allowing them
to stop what they regard as petty theft
petty theft remember in in California
that if it was under $1,000
it's okay so when they break a window in
San Francisco break a window in San
Francisco grab a backpack hey that's
only 1,000 bucks that's petty theft and
what do you get you get rampant crime
this guy that's not that's not petty
theft this guy just committed Grand
Theft which even a California is is five
grand that's grand theft five iPhones is
a 5,000 bucks that's Grand Theft just
Greenlight the Oakland Police Department
to do their job rather than handcuffing
them in a state that still has this
underlying
you know um defund the police thing and
now Gavin Newsome is sending Highway
Patrol people from Sacramento to go help
Oakland just let the police department
do their freaking job that's my well my
question to you is Tom what like going
all the way back Adam always says follow
the money so I'm trying to follow what
what in your right mind as a governor I
I get to defund the police but what what
is the like why are you trying to let it
so okay for them to steal and no no
security kick takas them I mean remember
that Zoom that he had it's
redistribution it's socialist
redistribution they they they want them
to steal they want they they're
incentivizing them to go go and do it
and you're not going to get in trouble I
feel like California is the epitome of
your feelings matter more than facts
yeah I feel like California is just this
it's it's we it's the most beautiful
state in the Union we get it it's
gorgeous the mountains the oceans the
beaches the highways it's so beautiful
but then when you when you peel back the
curtain so to speak and you look at the
actual data and the facts it's a
freaking disaster I I don't like I
everyone I talk I'm from I'm the only
one here who's never lived in California
right I've spent time there but I'm a
Florida guy I didn't really real I tell
the story all the time about how me and
Ricky would always argue about politics
what have you cuz I didn't fully
understand what an absolute show it
is literally out in California I had no
idea you know if it's different if you
go on vacation for a week or two you go
to La you see what's going on go to the
beach no big deal you go to a couple
parties go to you're not living there
you're not stepping over homeless people
you're not getting robbed at Mike Malik
was over here the other day he's he
showed us a video of a of a guy in his
house that day robbing his house
privately he showed that afterward sorry
I don't know that was a private thing
but he talked about it he basically said
California is like an ex-girlfriend that
you can't escape it just it just seems
like a slow drip of stories of see what
they did here in California see what
they did here in California you see
what's going on here see what's going on
here and then at what point are people
just be like if someone pushes you and
pushes you and pushes you and push you
at what point you going be like dude get
the off of me and you know and you
you want to trip out too I cuz I have
conversations with because I lived there
for almost 20 years right Adam I still
I'm getting text in a group text with me
and Brady of Liber like you know what
they're saying to me California is
getting better it's not that bad New
York is getting better these are
delusional people that can't admit when
something is broken bro because they're
going to look like crap because they're
so uh like dedicated to this point you
know I used to I used to think I used to
think in uh when I ran my insurance
company uh uh in every insurance company
in every business you run you you have
people that you can never win them over
ever they're they're delusional they're
complainers and they're always going to
complain and about the fact that
it's not fair I can't believe you did
this and da d d da and I spent first God
knows how how many years of my career
trying to convert those people until I
finally realize they're chronically crap
magnets and they've been like that their
entire lives and only they can change
themselves I can't crap magnets there is
80% of the world that are crap magnets
they attract bad to their lives
okay they attract drama they trct issues
there's always bad things happening to
them if you try to subscribe your life
to trying to convert crap magnets into
independent people you will live a very
miserable life I was miserable for many
years until I sat there and I realized
hey leave these guys alone because if if
you're trying to convert them over
they're eventually going to baptize you
into being a crap magnet you have to be
very careful with them spend time with
people who have hope who are reasonable
who are willing to have conversations
and if you can show and proof with d and
a decent argument and a good argument
and within time eventually they go and
do their own independent research
they're eventually going to say what
makes sense man yeah it makes sense man
when I first started talking about Texas
to my guys they're like this guy's out
of his mind i' never live in Texas
you're out of your freaking mind every
one of my original guys Vinnie when I
tell you Tom yes or no 100% of the
original guys that started with me that
were making less than 100K per year with
us
100% of them Vinnie are are all in Texas
are you and they're not in the same city
oh really but they're all in Texas and
they're chilling Austin Houston Dallas
you name it San Antonio I'm telling San
Antonio one they're all in Texas and by
the way they're not there just for the T
for the taxes these people and they move
their organizations there are thriving
and by the way they're great human
beings they're great leaders phenomenal
parents incredible parents
multi-millionaires financially free and
eventually because they could reason
okay because they were able to
understand the argument being made they
eventually said yeah of course this
makes sense what the hell am I doing
living in California yeah okay what am I
doing living in California going and
deal with deal and by the way we still
have a massive presence in California
the people that don't want to leave
they're like there's no way in the world
I'm going to leave California I'm here
ride or die whatever maybe they live in
some good conservative counties that
they kind of leave them alone each his
own totally get that what's the moral of
the story here the moral of the story
isn't you're going to convert everybody
you don't need to convert everybody
there's people that will never leave
that place why don't certain people live
certain countries that are just
absolutely terrible you can't leave the
80% of people that see themselves as
that they have an identity issue but
enough people are sitting there and
saying damn I can't do this anymore this
is getting crazy and these are not
liberals Republicans or Independents or
Libertarians these are just reasonable
people that are saying logically I can't
live in California anymore and they're
leaving enough of them are going to do
that in New York n DC in all these
different places even DC right here DC
supermarkets turn to high-tech security
gates as crime continues to search New
York NYPD ditches its
$12,500 Times Square Subway police robot
after only four months pull up this by
the way actually go to the video when
Eric Adams introduced the robots there
was a video to it go on Twitter and type
in Eric Adams New York robots just type
that in in the in the search you know
it's bad that the robots are
leaving you know New York has lost it
when the robots are like we're out of
here see if you can find this clip yeah
right there watch this okay this zoom in
a little bit a little bit around pull it
back he said this is four months ago big
deal Press Play devices like the K5 have
the possibility serve as determined to C
or at least learn best practices while
using technology going
forward
$12,500 a piece guess what what time
Square Subway police robots after 4
months they're ditching this $12,500
idea despite costing only $9 an hour and
being part of a 7mon pilot program the
$420 lb
53 inch egg shaped K5 police robot
failed to justify its expense now parked
in an empty storefront Gathering thus
public opinion on the robot's
Effectiveness was largely negative with
MTA passengers and residents criticizing
it as a waste of taxpayer money and
resources highlighting its inability to
climb stairs and need for human officers
to supervise but you know what the point
is the point is common sense prevails
yeah people are sitting there saying
what are we doing with these damn robots
right intention of this thing anyway
what supped to do supposed to all the
cameras it had a speaker and a bunch of
cameras you are being Ober actually had
a very good sound system it was playing
some real good hip-hop Smalls but yo you
ready for this the robot costs the
taxpayer $9 an hour but guess what it
had to be chaperoned by at least one or
two cops so we're paying the cop to
stand there next to it so Nobody messes
with it bro I don't know if you guys
know that there was an interview Rob I
don't think you're going to find it but
they asked to interview the the robot
like what's wrong and he's like the
mayor sucks and it just that's it it's
finished the May the mayor's not good
would you like to see the reaction of
New Yorkers as they pass by the Rob do
please it this is good yeah the hell out
of my
face get the F out of my
face I'm going to follow you
out of here hey do you have any weed do
you have any weed on you wait wait a
minute
face my C put your hands on the wall get
out of my face but New York but there
was a story where a couple of guys
grabbed their Rob and threw it in front
of a train they were they were trying to
push it off the edge onto the tracks my
God like I I have a wife I have a wife
and kids don't do it I have a microwave
at home I wonder if that's a crime by
the way yeah is it killing a cuz you
know if you hit a dog it's assult oh
miss my girlfriend the microwave yeah my
my wife is at home with the microwave
it's like no she is a microwave and
again going back to my point how much
bad crap can New York can they do
anything right can this mayor do
anything right nothing's working public
service announcement for Eric Adams Eric
Adams you need some Vault yeah unlock
your brain energy memory sharpness focus
and no sugar and no caffeine and it's
legal to take this in your luggage when
you go on trips to Central America
beautiful what's the story with Eric
Adams that he compared himself to Jesus
yeah we have that story said something
that play the clip Rob it's the second
half it's a minute clip and in the
second half he Compares himself to Jesus
he starts going into kind of a Down Home
the guy is just go to 2 second Tom right
the Press Play no listen that's why
people are hating on me great start prop
you trying to figure
out why they're hating on me they hating
on me because those how many you go to
church ma'am this is a Matthew 21-2
moment Jesus walked in the temple he saw
them doing wrong in the temple he did
what he turned the table over I went to
City Hall to turn the table
over first woman Police Commissioner of
color first Spanish speaking Police
Commissioner
firsters uh correction Comm commissioner
commissioner go through the line we're
doing $300 lowers by the way oh by the
way not just three did you see him in
the vest with a with a fendy uh scarf no
this is the
best Adams
he's you have Tom Tom hang on one second
watch this watch this under the
bulletproof vest under the bulletproof
vest bro that's where your money is
going that is hilarious he's wearing the
fendy vest under his is oh my good by
the way go to the price point of it to
the left they show how much it is right
now no no but no the right there uh
bottom right yes it's $7000000 scar oh
he's really channeling his inner hip-hop
rapper no he hold on Tom everything with
uh that he's talking about do you
remember when Nas used to have that song
with Diddy you could hate me now but I
won't stop now you can hate me now he's
trying to do a a a rap video 50 Cent Oh
God everything so it was basically 25
cent that's what PAB said after the
taxes he's an actor and now he's just
sort of CH channeling his inner Kanye
remember Kanye uh month ago when he went
on his Randy goes it's Jesus Trump yay
yeah now add uh add Eric Adams to all
that unbeliev no no no and by the way he
didn't pay that I've been to New York
and at you can go to 6th Avenue and 59th
which is right on the edge of Central
Park I saw a guy selling these on the
corner for 10 bucks yeah Tom they're on
every corner of New York I I don't think
the mayor is rocking a fake I think he's
going for the Gus how do you know he he
just got rid of the $122,000 Rob by the
way and he said he said the first female
police commissioner ma'am we want to buy
a robot that seems reasonable yeah
exactly that's what your Dei hire gets
you yeah and by the way go talking about
Dei this leads me to zoom zoom at one
point was the stock during covid when
you remember everybody and their mothers
wanted to be like oh my God where's the
zoom stock going to be going to is it
going to go to this should I should I
buy some of the stock well Zoom Cuts Dei
focused team as Corporate America
Retreats on diversity initiatives and by
the way this is not a story from Fox
Business it's a story from Bloomberg
even Bloomberg had to write this because
of how much of a hot mess this has
turned into with this Dei costing all
these company a bunch of money so let's
talk about this Zoom Video
Communications Inc has disband disbanded
it's teams dedicated to diversity equity
and inclusion initiatives amidst recent
layoffs opting to
engage external consultants for a
broader approach to inclusion with Chief
Operating Officer a parwa noting Zoom
needed to change its approach to Dei as
revealed in a memo while reiring
reaffirming the company's commitment to
Diva end Endeavors this move reflects a
wider 10 trend of corporate America
scaling back on diversity initiatives in
the face of conservative scrutiny with
companies like fizer Black Rock revising
their policies and and Tesla removing
the language supporting minority workers
from regulatory filings driving by
criticism from prominent figures
including Elon Musk and investors like
Bill akman amid a contentious debate
surrounding the effectiveness of di
strategies first of all bill acman is
not a conservative this is not a
conservative scrutiny this is called
Common Sense scrutiny it doesn't make
any sense right what is the one that you
have here Tesla
Chief billion Mar Cuban has spoken out
supporting it the Supreme Court's
decision to ban affirmative action from
college admissions embolden the
conservative group to uh Lodge
complaints against dozens of complaints
including American Airlines Macy's
McDonald's proof is in the pudding and
more and more companies are star to
realize this was a bad idea Tom thoughts
on this it is amazing thing when public
companies that have to file quarterly
reports and show earnings and show
progress suddenly sit back and go uh you
know you know maybe we just want to do
this based on Merit and kind of close
your eyes during an interview and just
ask people and interview them and find
out if they know how to do the job find
out through references if they did a
good job at their last job I don't care
if they're a 4 foot five Martian if they
can do the job let him do the job Merit
has never gone away it's been there but
it's been just covered up by this whole
Dei movement and this was a political
movement that gains Steam and it doesn't
work and it doesn't matter that the
Supreme Court uh ruling only was talking
about colleges and they got their
problems and saw the hearing in front of
the Congress and how that work Cuban is
still defending it though you've still
got islands and I call Cubans like The
Rock in the Stream he's the guy the
Rocks sticking up in the middle of the
stream their Waters going by he doesn't
seem to care and it didn't work and he's
trying to make his point and he's trying
to do all that and you still have those
things but there is common sense is
coming back if you know how to do your
job you're good at doing your job then I
don't care who you are what you look
like don't impose it on other people
just do your damn job we've got an
earnings report and I think the common
sense is coming back but it's being led
Pat by The Winds of capitalism blowing
toward Merit and ability and
accountability and you can't erase the
sins of the past by implementing sins
today that's something that we need to
take note of that's a t-shirt thank you
buddy I like that I think um you know we
can acknowledge what happened in America
prior to
1964 and say all right we definitely had
some systematic stuff that needed to be
addressed why do I say 1964 because
that's the year the Civil Rights Act
basically came out okay 1964 Landmark
civil rights case basically said that
you can it prohibits and I'll read it
word for word here prohibits
discrimination on the basis of race
color religion sex or national origin It
prohibits it that is system systematic
you talk about systematic racism that
stopped in 1964 Vinnie talks about all
the time you can't erase racism people
are going to be whites are going to be
racist blacks are going to be racist
Asian people Latino like people are
going to be people but systematically
there's nothing in place mandating this
so Dei is basically trying to reverse
the patriarchy who's the patriarchy
white men that started the country Oh
you mean white men like George
Washington and Thomas Jefferson and uh
John Adams people that basically started
our country yeah those guys yeah no no
no big deal about those guys but the the
whole conversation that Dei is the exact
opposite of this because this is this is
basically saying prohibiting
discrimination this is encouraging
discrimination on the basis of race
color religion sex it's just encouraging
not hiring straight white men yep and
you know yeah Tom you're screwed you're
you're screwed buddy um um so let's just
go back to to what this Civil Rights Act
was for and start living that kind of
life and a Bas on meritocracy you're
absolutely right well listen more and
more uh of these stories come out more
and more validates Common Sense prevails
but for a few years dumb ideas fool tens
of millions of people until Common Sense
people who are Relentless keep pushing
back okay do we want to go into U uh
let's go to the Disney story let's go to
the Disney story so who wins the battle
between the Disney board there's a lot
of stuff going on here with Disney and
it's not slowing down and it's just more
and more drama for Bob Iger so who wins
in the battle over Disney's board Tron
fund manager led by activist Nelson
pelts has nominated himself and former
Disney CFO Jay rasulo to Disney's board
aiming to shake up the Disney's
Direction after years of
underperformance try on holding nearly
two 2% of Disney's shares seeks to
replace two current board members Mar
Maria
Elena Lago masino and Michael foran with
pelts and rasulu replacing them
Blackwell's Capital another activist
investor has proposed its own slate of
three new directors in response to Tri
and campaign alleging that tring motives
stem from hostility towards former cobab
Iger rather than genuine concern about
Disney's performance the outcome of the
proxy battle will largely depend on
Institutional Investor as they hold
the majority of Disney's shares while
individual investors and Company
investors insiders have a smaller stake
their vote could still influence the
final decision and the ongoing struggle
over Disney's board compos compensation
composition Disney activist Black Walls
Black Walls propos of splitting up the
company in proxy again same story black
Wales floated the idea of Disney
separating its own real estate which it
says they represent about 44% of its
market cap caus into independent
publicly reads or series of investment
vehicles in which the shares can uh
interest uh uh can be distributed to
shareholders anyways with all the stuff
that's going on here you would think
Disney's learned from all these flops
back to back to back on what they're
going to do and by the way if Disney
really wants to make a big comeback
guess what they would do they would go
get on their knees and beg beg a man
named Johnny Depp Johnny will give you
$300 million you remember when they
asked Johnny the question can you pull
up Johnny Depp's response but asked
about Pirates of the Caribbean have you
seen his response oh brother dope oh my
Rob you've seen it before right when
Johnny Deb responds to Pirates of the
Caribbean if they paid him $31 million
would he take the job back his answer
tell me you find this Rob this is um and
when was this Patrick oh this is two
years ago Johnny Deb uh uh amber uh uh
this is the Amber herd um uh oh man Rob
if you the reaction when they asked him
Johnny Deb questioned maybe it's Johnny
Deb questioned well Tom before I go into
that time can you give some thoughts on
what's going on here with the Disney's
board because obviously try on I think
they're the sixth largest institutional
holder of shares in Disney and he's a
multi-billionaire two guys that are
fighting for this this guy's a one and
half billion doll guy I believe another
guy's a $4 and half billion dollar guy
he could be the one can you kind of pull
that up and give your thoughts on this
yeah so let me let me pull it back for
America this is your favorite sports
team
has missed the playoffs by missing the
shot at the end of the last game of the
regular season they missed the playoffs
you're upset all of these private Equity
ones you hear on the board they're the
players the players all want to win all
these investors in Disney want to win
they they are not winning on the stock
market they are not winning on profits
and so now the players are in the locker
room they've got the the old coach has
come back to coach them Bob Iger and now
the players are saying things to the
media what we need is more discipline
what we need is a is a different free
agent you've seen this Pat right the
players the players at the end of the
season are Unleashed and that's what
these so think of it that way America
think of it as or world the world that's
listening as this is a bunch of players
on the team that want to win these
private Equity people all have big
investment they want to make money they
all agree on one thing Disney is messed
up it's being and they had to bring Bob
Iger back to see if it could lead it out
of the ditch and everybody wants to
improved performance and they're all
saying that they have an idea to do it
and but they need control so they're all
arguing about having enough votes to get
control that's what that's what's going
on here when they say I want to put
directors here they want to have an
election and vote on what the direction
of Disney is then one of them has gone
public in Blackwell's capital and said
listen we've got theme parks we've got
hotels we've got TV and a lot of the
cable stations aren't doing well well
hey ESPN is doing so terribly Why Don't
We join voices with all of our enemies
and just make a super cable station good
idea bring me a proposal on that and
they're trying to to to say this is the
way to fix it they just want to make
money all these folks just want to make
money and Disney Is a Mess by check this
out watch the stats October of 2005 is
when Bob Iger becomes CEO of Disney
October of 2005 which is what roughly 19
years ago 18 years ago he BEC CEO right
at the time Disney's worth $47 billion
he becomes chairman in 2012 companies
worth $90 billion okay he steps down as
CEO and executive chairman February of
2020 at the top $328 billion crushing it
absolutely crushing it this is Disney
plus era right then 2021 he steps down
as executive chairman returns as SE on
November 2022 2014 valuation of Disney
was $160 billion 10 years later 20 uh
2024 valuation of Disney is roughly hter
$70 billion in 10 years valuation
increased only $10 billion okay that's
not a good thing that's 5% increase of
the company's valuation in 10 years by
the way that's like putting your money
in a savings account out of bank that's
the kind of returns Disney Brad is is
that correct or no that's exactly right
and that's why all these investors are
pissed so so then Nelson pels who owns
Tron Partners his netw worth is around
$1.5 billion he's a number six
institutional holder there's another guy
also Ike M who is a $45 billion guy he
sold Marvel to Disney he's one of the
biggest shareholders he owns a ton of
equity he's a pro-israel guy
conservative guy himself at this point
you know who owns the most Disney shares
institutional vanguard's number one
really they own 8% black rock is number
two 6.6% State Street is number three 4%
but the biggest owner in the last couple
months of of this buff no not at all is
actually South Park is is what the
biggest owner they've owned Disney and
Bob with the clips that they've done on
them okay so so now all this going on
like okay maybe they should go give
bring Johnny Deb back hey Bob you know
you've lost so much money the last
couple years the valuation went from
$328 billion to 170 billion you've lost
160 billion doll of
valuation the last two and a half three
years give her take guess what go pay
Johnny Depp pay him a half a billion
dollars beg him to come back beg him to
come back drop the press release okay
this guy's going to be worth this half a
billion dollars will take Disney from
170 to $220 billion cuz guys like us are
going to be like thank God they're
bringing them back then make
announcement there is no Dei lgbtq stuff
going on here give Johnny this they
asked Johnny the question in court
here's what Johnny had to say go ahead
Rob Mr Depp if Disney came to you with
$300 million and a million
alpacas nothing on this Earth would get
you to go back and work with Disney on a
Pirates of the Caribbean film correct
that is true Mr
rinor that is true by the way give him
500 million so guess what Disney
announces what so what's his name in the
movie what's Johnny de's name in the
movie Jack Sparrow Jack Sparrow you want
to know the new Jack Sparrow go ahead
and show him joking no no Go and show
the new Jack Sparrow go show no no no
it's better than a black guy the new
Jack SP no it's not the woman black
woman uping not female Le Pirates of the
Caribbean movie it's still the making
that Disney AO Ed deiri is being eyed to
Star as a character named an they want a
younger cast of pirates looking for
Hidden Treasure can I ask you a question
can I ask you and Tom you you two are
going to you got all three of you guys
are going to know better than me you see
the writing on the wall you've lost half
your money I know Vanguard they all have
an agenda but at what point are you like
guys enough is enough Tom if you're on
the board and you're seeing this and
you're not as woke Dei but you're losing
everything how much power do you have to
go guys you are absolutely not putting a
female to take the pirate do you think
she's straight or she's lesbian I don't
know she's a lesbian she's a okay she
was asked in January 10th of 2024 while
discussing her role as lesbian character
Jo and bottoms edry told I don't know if
she's a lesbian she played sen Rachel
talks lesbian fight comedy Rael I mean
listen do you understand what direction
they're going right now course but here
one thing the one thing that they they
have in common though whether it's
Johnny Depp or the lesbians the Pirates
they want that booty we know that booty
but listen but here's the thing though
it's like no listen we don't care I
don't care gay and all that the
character is Jack Sparrow end of story
bro without him you're not I'll I'll bet
anybody right now $10,000 to your $1,000
that is going to flop Rob Rob do Rob do
me a favor Rob go to Google and type in
the following is IO Ed a lesbian just
type that please and see what comes up
with a Wikipedia wait till you got go
zoom in please let's read this during
her junior year of college edry began
pursuing a career in comedy and intern
at Upright Citizens Brigade edry has
canvas for the Democratic Socialist
America and she identifies as queer all
you're going to do is
alienate 50 plus% of the country most
men are going to be like dude you know
all those gay lesbian black Pirates run
around back in the day no it was
white dudes
iar me out you see the new Mr Mrs Smith
if I saw that did you see that we going
to Makey Asia like forget about Brad P
if Bob came out and they announced came
out of theet press conference he's
standing next to uh Johnny Depp and they
announc $500 million no Dei no lgbtq we
going back to Old School Pirates of the
Caribbean what would happen to the
Disney stock the next day Tom Tom what
would happen if they announced Johnny
Depp comeback were giving him a half a
million half a billion dollars we begged
him to come back he agreed to do so we
apologized for the treatment of jump
into conclusion on what happened with
him with the Amber herd case he's one of
the greatest actors of our lifetime we
want to give him and the fans the
opportunity to see the next one being
made with him we don't see the brand
John you know P to the Caribbean what
what would happen to the stock I'm
actually curious what would Happ I'll
tell you what would happen because the
stock market doesn't care if you're
straight gay whatever they only care if
you're going to make money and that
would be a move that's going to bring
people to the theaters and is going to
make money in the face of this horrible
slate of failures the stock would pop
that day the stock would pop because you
know you know what money isn't is
agnostic they don't care about your your
and money is culturally blind money is
blind to Lifestyle money wants to know
that money is made that's how the stock
market works and guess what the stock
would pop because investors everywhere
behind the cover of Darkness behind
their computers would be like hey well
I'm buying because you know what that
means that means they're going to make
revenue on that movie I can't wait up
but if you want a real like uh a real
life view of what Dei looks like like
this is the most like antithetical
ironic you know the new uh Snow White
and the Seven Dwarves oh don't even stop
have you seen what the Seven Dwarves
look like yeah no no just show this for
us Rob if the audience has seen yet Mr
Mrs Smit so this isn't like dude I don't
care what it is as long it's a good
movie they're basically saying I mean is
there a more marginalized acting group
than the dwarves how many roles do they
possibly have not that
many you got Willow you got Wonka you
got loas right now you go to go to Seven
Dwarves
newcast they got one
dwarf one DW they got a black guy they
got a random white gay guy they got a
fat guy couple yeah like they're not
even hiring dwarfs they can't even have
seven dwarfs anymore let's get some
lesbians let's get an Asian dwarf in
there let's just get to the color of the
rainbow even the dwarf is uh an ampute
take a look his arm is missing he's not
even he's a Warf he's missing liked I
liked the old Seven Dwarves where it was
just metaphor for drug use you had
Sneezy he was a Coke freak you had sley
he was into Downs grumpy he was he was a
drunk bashful complete qu qualude kid
and then you had doc he was the
connection I liked it when the Seven
Dwarves were all about drugs that's it
the connection speaking of the
connection why does the bis doc AKA doc
know so much about the drug per Familia
game he's had a good time this this is
the line that Kirk Ras Lazarus said
right I know who I am
I'm the dude dressed as this dude
disguise as the other dude right like
wait a that's what that's what is here
you go okay all right let's go to do we
want to go Super Bowl do we want to do
one business we got to do Super Bowl's
coming up go all right Super Bowl
quarterback Brock pie ready this is the
starting quarterback of the 49ers the
guy made $870,000 this year you know how
much money that is some of you guys may
say well that's a lot of money Pat he's
Rich well guess what
16 football players made more money from
nil than this guy's making and he's
going to the damn Super Bowl imagine
what that feels like he goes to a
college campus a college campus
quarterback says how's it feel being
broke I make more money than you right
and nil kids 16 of them are making more
money than Brock pie so let me read the
story to
you so uh uh Brock py despite his role
at starting quarterback earns a
relatively modest salary of of $870,000
notably less than his counterpart
Patrick Mahomes ready he makes 44.5
million this year 44.5 million Patrick
no way Illustrated a significant
disparity in NFL player ratings
surprisingly party salaries eclipsed by
16 college football players who
capitalize on name image and likeness
and iil deals with top earners such as
shador Sanders and Arch Manning making
millions showcasing the financial
opportunities available to college
athletes since the NCAA change in 2022
while py supplements his income with
undisclosed off field endorsement from
companies like Alaska Air Alaska Air
Toyota Buffalo Wild Wings his average
annual contract is $943,000 places him
89th amongst NFL quarterbacks
underscoring the financial disparities
within the league they're not going to
call This Racist are they because
Mahomes you know what I'm saying and
he's like white are they being racist
towards White quarterbacks now is that
what's going on here I hope that's not
what the case is anyways
870 16 other n Adam thoughts well let me
tell you something you know so the you
know he was the last pick I'm sorry let
me just say this shador makes 4.7 Archie
Manning makes 2.8 wild in college Travis
Hunter makes 2.3 Quint eers makes 1.7
Alabama's Jaylen milro makes 1.5 million
go ahead these were all the biggest
names of college obviously everything
that Deion Sanders
did Manning let's take a look at a
football family there baby yeah that's
um the oldest man it's not it's a their
nephew it's pton
Eli El but here's the deal with this kid
Brock pie he's going to go potentially
from Mr Irrelevant right he was the last
pick in the entire 22 draft 2022 draft
the last pick is always known as Mr
Irrelevant to in three days time
potentially being the most relevant
talked about name on the planet if he
can single-handedly with his teammates
bring down the cabal of the S Off Taylor
Swift ain't going to happen brother uh
Travis Kelsey have put together he's
going to basically become the most
talked about name on the plan we're
going to bet at some point before this
what do you mean right now what do you
want to bet we're betting you said a
th000 bucks oh you want to bet wait cuz
it's a we're doing the spread what's the
spread of the Chiefs and what's it
called it's I think it's a point and a
half right oh now we're doing doing
spread why would I go a dumb bet what's
the spread point and a half is is really
oh it's minus two okay minus two 500
bucks well I got to see what line This
is well the CBS Sports is the line no
that's good go Vegas Insider go to Vegas
Insider it's like one or one and a half
there's no way they put this much effort
into Travis and twis for them to lose
well the the reason I'm placing this bet
is because I you're going to be rooting
for Taylor Swift 100% okay I'm going to
be rooting for San Francisco what's the
spread one and a half I believe Rob
where is it no it's minus two so you
okay so guess what you're giving me two
points let's do 500 bucks
500 bucks what the hell is two point so
two so mean so I know what it is what
I'm saying is like the last time I
looked it was one and a half so are we
doing two 500 bucks I thought we were
doing 1,000 bucks just do 500 bucks 500
bucks 500 bucks you guys saw here first
okay that's it so you're saying Chiefs
are winning no matter what but I W one
wa wait wait Vinnie Vinnie Vinnie you
got to make it a th000 you're playing
with house money I gave you 500 no no no
no no I don't because I love you Adam
and why why did Tom give you 500 again
for shoes for my suit but why did he
give you uh because he, to my neck but
but why cuz he used my name for likeness
cuz he's a shady politician just
oh without even getting your permission
let
me who discounted first Miami absolutely
no way they put that much effort into it
but P are we going to uh did you see the
Alejandro my orcus he's in Vegas no okay
so uh our friend uh alejando myz was in
Vegas and he was fiing questions about
Taylor Swift Adam's favorite uh safety
and the Super Bowl and he was asked
about Taylor Swift Super Bowl safety can
we he's in Vegas right now Chill by the
way the Border a mess he's in Las Vegas
San Francisco is going to be running
through that offensive line of Kansas
City like it's open border policy the
Super Bowl yeah let's
go incredible threats that are related
to Taylor Swift we uh are
extraordinarily Vigilant when we bring
65,000 people together in a stadium when
we have 330,000 people visiting a city
for a major sporting event and when we
have millions of people around the world
watching it our priority is the Safety
and Security of everyone in attendance
and that is what we are focused upon and
when there's an additional celebrity who
will bring more attention we are already
at a heightened state of vigilance and
fulfilling our responsibility just as we
do every single day by the way so first
of all it's funny it's funny how he's
talking about Vegas security so 65,000
people are going to be in the stadium uh
and there's 330,000 which I think that
number is pretty low they they're saying
it might be a little bit a little bit
higher like at 400,000 that are visiting
the city but he can literally care less
about the millions that he let come into
the border illegally which some are as
we've learned terrorists like remember
that friend of ours the guy from ozeran
the the terrorist that did what did he
do uh 12 years and he came to the border
and he said soon you guys are going to
know who I am where is that guy who no
nobody knows right which leads me into
what I told you before we came in here
Joe Buck uh made a statement which
should kind of bother people Patrick he
said there will be a Vegas related mess
of a Super Bowl story he said and I
quote this a quote there's going to be
some story there's going to be something
that happens because it's Vegas and it
won't stay in Vegas he's not talking
about Herpes okay he goes it's going to
be a big something that happens I don't
know what it is I have no idea I just
think that is going to be a mess in my
mind and by the way he won't be in Vegas
for Sunday rematch though he said he had
no desire to be there weird oh really he
won't be there he said he won't be there
I do not have any desire to be there
says Buck what yep keep going go ahead
and he goes I'm not I'm not I'm not that
way I'm not looking for the maximum
party and going out on night I'm just
going to do my thing and then uh combine
that with Vegas there's going to be so
so wait what why would he say something
like that when all of we've been hearing
from all these pundit on MSNBC and
there's going to be a Black Swan of it
remember let's not forget they've been
I'm not saying something's going to
happen Buck is not a party guy that part
is true Joe Buck is absolutely I know
people in baseball that know him very
well Buck is not a party what he talking
about though Patrick what is maybe maybe
he's just talking about he doesn't want
to party like there's who said it but
he's not a party guy one of you ever
heard of him staying in Vegas and
partying there's going to be some story
there's going to be some something that
happens that's a weird prediction you're
looking for something that doesn't exist
no not I'm reading the words I
understand is that cardian I don't think
that Joe Buck's talking about well let
me ask you you want to make a prediction
my Arcus would know he uh he uh barely
missed impeachment on a two-point line
weird my orcus is more worried about the
Vegas border than the southern border
that's what he's wor he's trying to
protect the Vegas border what's your bet
Tom who do you have Kansas City or San
Francisco um you better give the right
one because you're going to go home
tonight yeah okay in in my house
uh I'm Raider Nation to the Bone and so
I have a natural anti-as City part of my
heart because Kansas City and Denver
have always been the the enemies of the
of Raider Nation and I've had nothing to
cheer about over the last couple years
uh San Francisco is Kim's team to the
Bone absolutely to the Bone my heart
hopes that I see her cheer for her team
and they win my mind says that this team
you know what this now fourth Super Bowl
in 5 years and Andy Reid I deeply
respect him I think Kansas City is going
to find a way to do this Adam what's
yours cuz I have something funny to add
go ahead I want to know listen to would
I like to see pie pie be a great story
be all that that'd be a great story yeah
I I I think I think Pat Mahomes is
trying to be trying to be over doing
everything Brady ever did I think
Mahomes coming for the throne I think he
wants it all and I think Kelsey uh got
momentum in the last game
he was fired up he is angry he's going
to play Angry he's going to play
agitated for the way they're treating
him because he is wanting to prove a
point because remember when he started
dating uh Taylor Swift first what
happened to him nothing for no to one
touchdown in seven games or something
like right but they were down they were
like losing horribly and all the
headlines said he was being brought down
by he threw Tucker's uh what do you call
it the kickers uh uh holder you know off
and he's like you know playing
aggressive talking smack to the line you
could tell he had a chip and by the way
here's what you have to realize what do
you think opponents are talk saying to
Kelsey actually think about it what our
opponent saying to Kelsey when they're
trying to get under his skin think about
hey Mr Swift hey Mr Swift what if I was
if I I wouldn't say that boy Mr Swift
the NL they're not going to Sayer boy in
N linebacker hey Mr Swift so I think I
think KY uh uh if he wants to have that
kind of a legacy he has to win this one
I do believe there's a camp that
believes pie is the next Brady I don't
know why when I when I talk to guys that
want to find the next Brady not Mahomes
when they want to find the next Brady
they say p is a closer story to Brady
because he's what Mr Irrelevant right
you're coming from being that so they
want to have somebody root for and to me
Mahomes gives the vibe of somebody you
root against p is somebody that comes
across as you root for but I think in
this instance who wins Casey has way too
many weapons weapons and you want to you
want to Tri you think KC has way too
many weapons San Francisco has a lot of
weapons I understand who they are
they're you know what they're doing
their defense but they have a guy on the
other right his name his his name is
Mahomes yeah he's been been there done
that that's a that's a big stage and by
just randomly Mike just sent me a a a
clip I mean a link did you guys know
that besides all the betting you know
coin toss Gatorade color all that stuff
there's a crazier prop bet uh offered by
bado and guess what it is there's
apparently I swear to God a0 1% chance
that aliens will invade Las Vegas
leading to the Game ending in a tie and
you can make a bet on it right now this
is a bado bet other bets I'm dead
serious Patrick but that's not crazy to
you how about this one Chiefs win Taylor
accompanies the team to the White House
where she endorses President Biden he
sniffs her hair and there's a 2% chance
of that or how about these Chiefs win
Travis and Taylor announced they're
expecting a baby that's a 4.8% likely
bet on bado you could bet on an alien
landing W you can bet on anything you
know it's really interesting for all the
this is um for all the football guys out
there I I dive into this and I should do
more of this on uh bisoc and talk about
it but Kyle Shanahan had in training
camp Jimmy Garoppolo and perie and Trey
Lance and you know they were grappo was
getting hurt a lot I mean he he was just
a guy that couldn't keep the ankles
healthy remember he was it was always
foot injury you're really really getting
in here so love it and then Trey Lance
got hurt Trey Lance was the future he
was a running quarterback similar to the
running quarterbacks that we have in the
NFL and Trey Lance got hurt and that's
how pry got his chance now Tre Lance
hadn't elevated himself up and wasn't
nearly as capable as bledo but
PR well because bledo got hurt and Brady
came up but it was Trey Lance was the
guy with the contract the big signing
the big draft pick he was supposed to be
the guy and he got hurt and um and that
led to PR's opportunity so there's a lot
of things here but Kyle Shanahan said
this I always thought that prie was the
best of the three of them and the
assistant coaches were there said that
he said you watch two years from now I
think that will be our starter it just
happened earlier because the injury this
to me comes down to two things the
better team versus the better storyline
everyone's rooting for the storyline
Travis and Taylor Swift what's going on
there is he is he gonna help elect I
don't want to hear is it gonna help
elect Joe Biden is she going to come
down she's not even performing there
okay is is is what's his name father
going to user's performing is u m
father for DUI listen that guy likes the
party bro who'll be there for the Super
Bowl a dream and his brother by the way
is going to be floating around that
entire Stadium cuz his
brother definitely not straight uh so
you and I a guys everybody out there I
got San Francisco you got KC got KC Rob
well we're about to be done but guess
what they know bro Taylor Swift is she
going to the game she'll probably be
there she'll cancel the whole tour
because what do you mean is she going to
the game well she has a tour date she
has a tour date on the day of the Super
Bowl figure outwear she's like in Japan
or something yeah she's supposed to be
in Japan but toky Tokyo so she will not
be at the Super Bowl she's going to go
she'll take a private jet don't figure
they might delay the game a little bit
for Taylor Swift you never know there's
reports that she can make it in time if
from the of her concert in Tokyo I think
it was like she's going to cross uh half
a dozen time zones in order to get there
in time but they've cleared a spot for
her private jet private airport she sold
one she sold one of her jet one of her
private jets but the other they saved a
parking spot for her and those in Vegas
when you have the Super Bowl they sell
out months in advance so they held a
parking spot for her all reports
indicate she's going to go yesterday
Travis Kelce said she may not be in ATT
tenant just heightening the let me tell
you something Rob that's exactly what
she's she's going a par you hang on but
she she doesn't need to be there for the
kick off she just needs to be there at
the end but I'd love to see her at the
halftime show walking while Usher is
performing she's up there holding up her
new Grammys no what do you mean she's
going to parachute in and like baby
hopefully she crashes into the the the
field or she starts singing and does her
own Super Bowl show I'm just saying but
now guess what now because I can care
less about sports now I'm in it for the
Chiefs baby now you're rooting now
you're rooting for everything you stand
against now I can't wait for the this is
why you're a hypocrite
this is why you're hypocrite for $500
you're bought and sold you're rooting
for everything you stand
against kelb
restore Taylor Swift and the scop you're
now rooting for that
$500 don't care about none of that
brother me takes a lot of heat on this
podcast rooting for San
Francisco do you have the winners for
gear let's do the gear real quick uh we
got to honor some viewers here baby
future look Sprite here for those of you
guys that did what you did today we're
going to uh give two tickets away to
those who ordered is this all the order
numbers right correct so we have all the
order numbers in there so if you order
that's all the people that placed an
order that's the only way we can do it
and Rob if you want to go two winners go
ahead and give the or can I say the
names or no it's just going to be the
order number winners we'll get you the
names uh in a second but the uh it's
just going to show order numbers and
then the sales team will get us the and
then they'll text the name okay so go
forward let's do the for exting one
ticket to the god it's a lot of Wheel of
Fortune right there how many is that
let's see who this first
one order number 13404 Okay order number
13404 whoever's in the back write it
down if you're if you're watching this
your order 13404 just say I'm order
13404 Rob keep going do another one it
baby congratulations so that's one come
on baby another one go for
[Music]
here we
go
15501 what I'm just guessing a number
Adam damn it
13063 Rob if you got the names if you
can give it to me so I can announce it
wow uh uh that's a lot of orders huh
yeah if you got the name send it to me
Rob will'll announce them they're
getting them now uh so again if your
order is 13404 or
1363 you are the winner we will contact
you um and I'll get you those names in
just a okay got it and meanwhile
remember for anybody that places an
order today on this podcast any two
Gears of future looks bright a hat and a
shirt any color hat any color shirt we
want a million people in the world
wearing this gear to shock the hell out
of everybody to say why are a million
people so optimistic about the future
that is what the value tment line
represents we believe the future looks
bright buy hat buy a shirt next Tuesday
this is going to last by next Tuesday
next Tuesday we'll announce the raffle
on this podcast we'll give away sign
gloves of Ryan Garcia sign balls of
Trevor brow and five sign books of
choose your enemies wisely have a great
weekend everybody I think we do have a
podcast that'll come tomorrow and that
podcast tomorrow is going to be with I
believe Rapa Port so if you know who
rap I have the names go for it uh aland
Ro Kian okay uh 13404 that's the winner
Andro Adam singer
1306 I love it Adam singer and Alejandra
congratulations guys reach out to the
team we'll get the stuff uh over to you
guys so you have the tickets for the
vault and can't wait to spend three days
with you guys at Palm Beach Convention
Center take care everybody bye- bye
bye-bye
[Music]